so what say you basketball fans would
giannis
be an mvp caliber player in the 80s and
the 90s yes or no scan the qr code zeke
in the 80s absolutely yeah i had a
feeling
absolutely wait come on let's be for
real now okay
i remember in the 80s there was a guy by
the name of ralph sampson okay
ralph sampson and hakeem elijah won
before ralph sampson got hurt
they were saying that ralph sampson was
going to be i remember bill russell
saying ralph sampson can be the greatest
player ever because of his skill set his
ability to handle the ball his ability
to play around the baskets his ability
to block shots
giannis is today's ralph sampson and all
these guys talking about what giannis
couldn't play and all that dude
ian is going around oakley giannis going
around all them he dunking on them he
landed he bigger he faster he's stronger
you can talk all that stuff because you
don't play no more you can talk all that
stuff cause you got gray hair and you're
sitting on the sidelines smoking cigars
about what you used to do that dude
would dog you
single time y'all stepped on the court
now you may hit him hard okay all right
after you hit him hard you ain't got no
game you ain't got no game okay so if
you hit me and i'd be like okay that's
all you got
you ain't got number to hit
i'm getting ready to mess over you
and giannis just like he treating them
now
he's bigger faster stronger he'll be
dunking on all them left-handed just
like ralph sampson was dunking on him
giannis would be doing the same thing so
all y'all stopping with he wouldn't
dominate in the 80s we never seen no
dude like this come into our league and
give him his props give him his credit
he would dog anybody in the 80s 90s 2000
and and and
30 20 when we get there